some great conversations happening over
at the David Pakman show reddit david
pakman.com slash our EDD IT we are just
shy of 19,000 subscribers to our
subreddit one of the largest independent
progressive media subreddits out there
that's a true statement fact check me I
welcome it david pakman.com slash read
it a few things i spotted this morning a
post about anti lockdown protesters
harassing coronavirus nurses at the
arizona protest yeah this is getting
very ugly and i asked on my twitter
today whether other countries are
dealing with these types of wacky
protests I guess Brazil is having some
and we we see who is in charge in Brazil
and maybe that makes sense but for the
most part this is almost at least in
this form this is almost a completely
uniquely American thing and you know I
guess it would be naivete to imagine
that we would simply be united against
the virus but we you actually have
people who while they aren't campaigning
for the virus their actions are
effectively promoting the spread of the
virus nurses are being harassed we've
seen nurses get pulled into protests
because the protests in some cases have
been actually stopping traffic they call
it operation gridlock in some cases and
ambulances can't bring patients to the
hospital which is absolutely depraved
and delusional if you think that that's
going to help get things opened up more
quickly so really horrible stuff I
appreciate Portland hipster for posting
that to the subreddit user Greg Hef
posted an article about an individual in
New York bar bar owner who has died from
corona virus who watched Fox believed
that everything was under control
believed that the lock downs in the
quarantines and everything were
overblown and that New York bar owner
has now died of corona virus now I want
to just take this as an opportunity to
restate there are some people I'm seeing
very anecdotally and I'm not even I
don't even know where they are
politically who are sort of relishing
and taking pleasure in individuals who
doubted the seriousness of the virus and
then died or had a family member die I
take no pleasure in that and this is not
about try
to baby or nanny state people into
safety but I just don't take pleasure in
people dying regardless right and I'm
against the death penalty even
Republicans even trumpets I don't want
anybody getting the virus I don't want
anybody dying now what I have said is if
people insist on protesting and engaging
in dangerous behavior if they were only
putting themselves at risk I would care
a lot less about it I still wouldn't
hope that they would die but I would at
least say listen ultimately they're only
responsible for themselves when they do
this but that's not the case they spread
the virus to other people other people
die people who are following the
guidelines are dying and that's a very
very tragic thing and I take no pleasure
in this dude dying or anybody else who
didn't believe how serious it was
lastly Brody Mulligan posted to Reddit
something that to many is cryptic he
posted
Oh mr. Pakman you know the capital of
Colombia Liz me of responded we are
continuing the pivotal arc on the David
Pakman show and I am determined to
figure out what country caller Pedro
really is from and my prediction is we
may hear from him on live calls on the
Friday show but a lot of people very
wrapped up it's a it's a an episodic
some episodic levity in very very
serious times if you don't know what I'm
talking about you probably will very
soon just Google Pedro on our YouTube
channel join the discussion at david
pakman.com slash read it privacy calm is
one of our sponsors and they're giving
you $5.00 just for using their free
service at privacy calm slash Pakman
privacy's of service I've been using for
a while now I love it it saves me a
bunch of headaches it's completely free
and it's very quick to set up and here's
how it works
when you pay for something online or
over the phone instead of exposing your
real credit card number
privacy lets you generate virtual card
numbers the payments are withdrawn from
your checking account but your real card
number stays completely private and you
do it all with one click you can
autofill the card number
in your web browser on the phone you can
create 12 virtual cards a month you can
set spending limits freeze them delete
them whenever you want I especially love
it for free trials where you need to
give a credit card number because I can
destroy the virtual card number as soon
as I give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are your real
credit card number is protected from the
data breaches that happen unfortunately
more often than we would like and it's
completely free they do have a paid
version with different tiers where you
can create more virtual credit card
numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a
no-brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft that costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you $5.00 to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy calm slash Pakman